TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS SAY THREE
PEOPLE WERE KILLED AND CNN
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY EDITOR
NICK PATON WALSH JOINS ME NOW.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THE RUSSIAN MISSILE ATTACK IN
UKRAINE.
THEY'RE STILL GOING AFTER
CIVILIANS.
NOTHING MUCH HAS CHANGED ON THAT
FRONT.
>> Reporter: IT'S AN UTTERLY
GHASTLY SCENE.
HUNDREDS OF RESCUERS COMBING
THROUGH THE DAMAGE TO THE
APARTMENT BLOCKS WHERE WE NOW
KNOW THE DEATH POLL TO BE 13, 80
PEOPLE INJURED.
BARE THIS IN MIND, TOTALLY
INNOCENT CIVILIAN BLOCK BY WHAT
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN SIX CRUISE
MISSILES AND POSSIBLY 16
ANTI-AIRCRAFT MISSILES, FIRED BY
A STRATEGIC BOMBER AND STEALTH
JET FLYING INTO UKRAINE.
THE CRUISE MISSILES FREQUENTLY
USED ACROSS UKRAINE.
ANTIAIRCRAFT MISSILES BEING
DEPLOYED BECAUSE THE INVENTORY
OF OTHER MISSILES IS DEPLETED.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME
ZAPORIZHZHIA HAS BEEN HIT, JIM.
THIS WEEK IT'S ONE OF A NUMBER
OF ATTACKS WE'VE SEEN.
IT FORMS PART OF A PATTERN THAT
UKRAINIANS SAY IS INDISCRIMINATE
BOMBING AGAINST CIVILIAN
TARGETS.
SOME WONDER IF THIS IS
RETALIATION FOR THE ATTACK ON
THE BRIDGE, THE VITAL PART OF
THE RUSSIAN FRVGT THAT FEEDS THE
OCCUPATION OF CRIMEA, THE
UKRAINIAN PENINSULA THEY
ILLEGALLY ANNEXED IN 2014.
ZAPORIZHZHIANS WOULD SAY THEY'VE
BEEN HIT EVERY DAY, EVEN BEFORE
THAT OCCURRED.
RUSSIA'S PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
PUTIN MEETING THE HEAD OF HIS
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE AND
SAYING THAT AS A RESULT OF THE
REPORT HE'S RECEIVED FROM THAT
COMMITTEE, THEY BELIEVE THAT THE
UKRAINIAN SECRET SERVICES WERE
RESPONSIBLE WITH WHAT HE
REFERRED TO AS FOREIGNERS.
IT'S STILL UNCLEAR EXACTLY HOW
THIS EXPLOSION OCCURRED.
WAS IT A TRUCK BOMB?
WAS SOMETHING ELSE INVOLVED?
THE DAMAGE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT.
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA BEING VERY
CLEAR IN THEIR MIND THEY'RE ABLE
TO GET CARS MOVING ACROSS THE
DAMAGED ROAD AREAS AND THE RAIL
TRAFFIC HAS RESUMED.
IT'S SO VITAL FOR RUSSIA'S
SUPPLY OF ITS TROOPS IN THE
SOUTH OF UKRAINE, SUPPLY THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN ATROCIOUS AND PART
OF WHY THESE PETITIONS ARE
SLOWLY COLLAPSING.
THERE WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
MEETING IN MOSCOW TOMORROW OF
RUSSIA'S SECURITY COUNCIL.
YES, THEY HAPPEN WEEKLY, BUT
THIS PARTICULAR ONE OF GREAT
EMPHASIS.
WE MAY LEARN EXACTLY WHAT
RUSSIA'S RESPONSE WILL BE.
THIS TO VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS A
BRIDGE OF GREAT SIGNIFICANCE.
HE OPENED IT PERSONALLY IN 2018
BY DRIVING A TRUCK ACROSS IT.
THE IDEA THAT UKRAINE COULD
ATTACK IT, STARTLING, FRANKLY,
IN TERMS OF A SIGN OF THEIR
CAPABILITIES VERY SES THE
COLLAPSED IN RUSSIAN.
RUSSIA'S SPOKESPERSON WAS ASKED
WHETHER THIS WOULD INVOKE THE
NUCLEAR DOCTRINE ABOUT WRUSH
YEAH DEPENDING ITS OWN
TERRITORY.
HIS RESPONSE TO THAT QUESTION
WAS INAPPROPRIATE.
WE KNOW RUSSIA IS LOSING DAY
AFTER DAY AFTER DAY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, IN TERMS OF THE
SYMBOLISM, MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
BEING ATTACKED.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE WHAT
THE KREMLIN RESPONSE IS
TOMORROW.
JIM.
>> NICK PEYTON CAL WALSH, THANK
YOU.
>>> JOINING ME IS RETIRED
GENERAL MARK KIMMITT.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
IT SEEMS RUSSIA IS HELLBENT ON
RETALIATING FOR THE HUMILIATION
OF THAT BRIDGE BEING BLOWN UP.
WHAT DO YOU SEE NOW WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE UKRAINIANS WERE
ABLE TO PULL OFF AND WHAT
APPEARS TO BE AN ACT OF RUSSIAN
RETILL ASIAN, GOING AFTER
CIVILIANS AS THEY'VE DONE TIME
AND AGAIN.
>> IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THIS WAS
NOT A UKRAINIAN OPERATION.
WITHIN 24 HOURS THEY WERE
ISSUING A STAMP WITH AN ATTACK
ON THE CRIMEAN BRIDGE PUT ON THE
STAMP.
PRETTY CONCLUSIVE TO ME THAT
THAT WAS DONE BY THE UKRAINIANS.
WITH REGARDS TO THE RETALIATION,
I THINK THAT COMES AT THE SAME
TIME YOU'VE GOT THE GENERAL
TAKING OVER THE ENTIRE
OPERATIONS INSIDE OF UKRAINE.
HE'S WELL KNOWN TO BE LIKE HIS
PREDECESSOR DA VORN KOF, A
VETERAN OF SYRIA.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF DOING THE
MASSIVE BOMBING INSIDE ALEPPO.
I SUSPECT HE'S COMING IN NOT
ONLY TO PROVE THAT THEY CAN
RESPOND TO THE ATTACK ON THE
BRIDGE BUT ALSO TO DEMONSTRATE
WHAT A TOUGH COMMANDER HE'S
GOING TO BE ON THE RUSSIAN
FORCES INSIDE UKRAINE.
>> BEFORE WHAT HAPPENED THIS
WEEKEND, AND IT'S BEEN A LOT,
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS WARNING OF
NUCLEAR ARMAGEDDON.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTS PUTIN TO
COME TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
I GUESS I'M WONDERING WHAT DO
YOU MAKE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
REMARK?
ARE WE GETTING TO THAT KIND OF A
CRITICAL STAGE?
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT WAS AN UNFORTUNATE
CHOICE OF WORDS.
I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
DIMINISH THE USE OF A NUCLEAR
WEAPON INSIDE OF UKRAINE.
THE FACT REMAINS THERE'S A BIG
STEP BETWEEN USING A TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPON INSIDE UKRAINE
AND THERMAL NUCLEAR WAR WITH
STRATEGIC WEAPONS BETWEEN RUSSIA
AND THE UNITED STATES AND THE
FREE WORLD.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM OF TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, IT WOULD REDUCE
A THRESHOLD THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE
SINCE 1945.
>> DO YOU THINK PUTIN COULD GO
THAT ROUTE?
HE MIGHT EMPLOY THESE TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS OUT OF SHEER
DESPERATION?
>> IT'S RUSSIAN DOCTRINE THAT IF
RUSSIAN PROPERTY, RUSSIAN
TERRITORY IS ATTACKED, THAT THE
USE OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS IS AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE.
I WOULD REMIND EVERYONE THAT WE
USED TO HAVE VERY, VERY SMALL
TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT
WERE ABOUT 100 POUNDS AND RANGED
ABOUT 850 METERS.
IT SHOULD NOT BE THE END OF THE
WORLD, IT SHOULD NOT LEAD TO
NUCLEAR WAR.
WE'D BETTER, ALTHOUGH, HAVE SOME
VERY, VERY SIGNIFICANT RESPONSES
TO PUTIN AND HIS FORCES IF THOSE
WEAPONS ARE RELEASED ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
>> WE'RE HEARING STORIES OF
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS BEING
COMPLETELY ILL-EQUIPPED.
IT'S ALMOST COMICAL IN SOME
CASES.
IN ONE CASE THEY MOVED INTO A
PIG SHED IN KHERSON BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO
SAY.
WE'RE SEEING VIDEOS OF RUSSIAN
OFFICERS TELLING TROOPS THEY'LL
HAVE TO BRING THEIR OWN SLEEPING
BAGS AND SAYING THEY'RE FIT TO
SERVE IF THEY HAVE HERNIAS OR
METAL PLATES IN THEIR HEADS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN AS FAR AS
HOW THE RUSSIAN MILITARY HAS
BEEN DEGRADED BY UKRAINIANS?
>> TWO THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S PRETTY
EMBARRASSING TO SEE HOW THEY'RE
TREATING THEIR TROOPS.
I COMMANDED RUSSIAN TROOPS THAT
WERE WORKING WITH OUR BRIGADE
INSIDE BOSNIA IN 1997 AND '98.
THEY'RE USED TO WORKING UNDER A
SCALE OF PRIVATION THAT
AMERICANS WOULDN'T AK KEPT.
THEY HAD COLD SHOWERS IN THE
WINTER, VERY POOR FOOD.
THIS IS THE RUSSIAN WAY OF WAR,
DON'T TAKE CARE OF YOUR TROOPS
AND JUST MAKE THEM FIGHT.
>> WOW.
FORBES IS REPORTING THAT 700,000
RUSSIANS HAVE FLED SINCE THE
DRAFT WAS ANNOUNCED.
WHAT DO YOU -- I'M SURE YOU'VE
SEEN THESE IMAGES OF THESE
RUSSIANS FLEEING -- CROSSING
INTO PLACES ALL AROUND THE
FORMER SOVIET UNION, INTO THESE
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES.
DO YOU THINK THIS SPELLS CRACKS
IN PUTIN'S POWER?
>> WELL, WHAT IT INDICATES IS
THAT THE WAR HAS NOW COME TO THE
PEOPLE OF RUSSIA.
HE TRIED TO KEEP THIS AS A
SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION,
FOCUSED INSIDE OF UKRAINE WITH A
SMALL NUMBER OF TROOPS.
THAT IS OVER.
NOW THAT HE'S GONE TO
MOBILIZATION OF THE RESERVISTS,
PEOPLE BACK IN MOSCOW AND THE
OUTLYING CITIES UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS WAR IS NOW THEIR WAR, AND
SOME ARE VOTING WITH THEIR FEET.
THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR PRESIDENT
PUTIN.
ONE QUESTION IS WHETHER AN
AUTOCRAT REALLY WORRIES ABOUT
PUBLIC OPINION.
IF HE DOES, HE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED.
>> APPARENTLY, GENERAL KIMMITT,
HE'S GOING TO BE MEETING WITH
HIS NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM IN
THE NEXT DAY OR SO.
IS THERE ANY HOPE -- I HESITATE
TO EVEN ASK THIS QUESTION --
THAT ANYBODY IS GOING TO TALK
SENSE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN, GIVE
HIM ANY SENSE OF WHAT THE
REALITY OF THE SITUATION IS?
OR HE JUST DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR
THAT?
>> THIS IS STARTING TO RESEMBLE
HITLER IN HIS BUNKER IN 1945,
TAKING ADVICE FROM HIS
COMMANDERS ON THE GROUND, NONE
OF WHO THOUGHT THERE WAS ANY
CHANCE THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
WIN, AND AS THEY DID, TEMERIZE
THEIR WORDS TO THE DICTATOR FOR
FEAR OF THEIR OWN LIVES FOR
TELLING THE TRUTH, I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT'S THE SAME CONCERN
OF HIS ADVISERS.
CANDIDLY, IF PUTIN GOES DOWN,
HIS HAND-SELECTED ADVISERS ARE
GOING WITH HIM.
I WOULD SUSPECT HE'S GOING TO
HANG IN THERE REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE ADVISEERS SAY.
FRANKLY, I DON'T THINK THE
ADVISERS ARE GOING TO GIVE HIM
THE ADVICE THAT